campaigners on both sides are wishing
donald trump
well that with the country in crisis and
just 31 days to go
until the election people are starting
to wonder seriously
what happens if the president doesn't
recover fairly soon
the u.s constitution sets out the
process
and this is the really crucial section
the 25th amendment which has
almost every eventuality covered
here's what happens if the president is
communicative but unable to carry
on however temporarily donald trump
would have to write that he's handing
over his duties to the vice president
mike pence
but if he's unexpectedly incapacitated a
majority of the cabinet needs to agree
that it is in fact
mr pence who takes charge for mr trump
to regain power after this
congress would have to be convinced that
he had sufficiently recovered
if two-thirds of both chambers vote to
disagree
vice president pence would stay in
charge until the next election
so the 3rd of november
pence might become acting president at
this point
if trump is ill enough for example if he
was moved into icu
they might say that they were going to
make pence acting president it has
happened in the past that
a nominee has died uh
between the point at which his party
nominated him for the presidency
and the election that has happened and
when that happens again there are clear
rules
the party then decides who the nominee
is
but for a sitting u.s president it is
real uncharted territory
if donald trump is unable to stand in
the u.s election
it's even more chaotic because more than
a million postal votes
have already been cast in that event it
would come down
to the electoral college those bound by
law to vote for a candidate
based on the results of the election in
their state but if who they've been
mandated to vote for isn't available
anymore
there are no rules to follow the
presidential
and vice presidential candidate run
together so electors could stay loyal to
their party by
switching their vote to mike pence
alternatively
electors could be released from their
pledge to vote for president trump
and vote for joe biden instead it's
congress though who ultimately counts
those electoral college votes
and they could follow a completely
different course
whether a state or a national level if
president trump's condition does worsen
this will likely end up in the courts
since 1778 the u.s election has
proceeded as planned even
in the most tumultuous times through
civil war
and two world wars that the coronavirus
continues to change the course of
history